-Our first guest tonight
is a journalist you know
from Showtime's "The Circus,"
"CBS Saturday Morning"
and "The Mole."
She is the host of "Alex Wagner
Tonight," which airs
Tuesdays through Fridays
on MSNBC.
Please welcome to the show
Alex Wagner, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's so nice to have you here.
-It was so nice to take the
elevator up a few floors.
-It's lovely to have you back
in the building.
You're hosting the 9:00 p.m.
hour on MSNBC.
-I am.
-Tuesdays to Fridays.
One of the really exciting
things about it is
you're the only Asian American
hosting a cable prime-time show.
Is that something that is both,
I don't know, is it humbling?
Is it frustrating
that it's true?
-Yes, it is both of
those things.
It's absolutely humbling to be
representing a huge diaspora
that is definitely
not all within me.
I mean, Asian Americans are
wildly diverse.
I'm so proud to be
Burmese American.
I'm so proud to have the
heritage that I do, and I try
and do my best to,
you know, represent
that part of the world
on our show.
But it's insane that
in the year 2023,
I'm the only Asian American
prime-time cable news host.
That should not be.
-Well, hopefully you're
the first of many.
Hopefully this is the beginning
of something.
But I also want to ask,
you've hosted a show before,
but this is a big one.
-Yeah.
-It must make it a little bit
easier because
you have a great many friends
over at MSNBC.
Including you threw up a tweet
of you and Chris Hayes.
So you and Chris have known
each other 25 years?
-Oh, my God, and we're only 27.
-That's so weird.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Like, from a very young age.
We've known each other since,
like, acne days.
-Really?
-That's how long --
-You saw Chris Hayes with acne?
-I'm not saying
whose acne it was.
I'm just saying that's how
long -- our hormones were in a
different place, and now they're
going into another place.
But yeah, we've known each other
since college.
And I remember -- he's a year
younger than me, and when he got
into our college, Brown, I
remember the upperclassmen were
like, "Chris Hayes is
coming to Brown."
And I was like, "Who is this
Chris Hayes?"
And now I know
what the fuss was about.
-Chris Hayes was so cool,
people at college
knew him before he got there?
-Let's say -- is it coolness?
I don't know.
Notoriety. I'm just going to say
notoriety.
I can say that as someone who
loves him deeply
and has known him
a very long time.
-You received some advice,
and I received the same thing
when I started this show.
And again, you've had
your own show before,
so I know it's a little bit
different.
But how long it takes to be
comfortable
behind the desk of
your own show.
I know you've just started this.
-Yeah.
-But do you feel like you're
there yet
and what is the date
you have on the calendar
for where you want to be
comfortable?
-It's March of 2079 is
when I'm going to
start feeling comfortable, Seth.
I think -- I'm very -- I don't
know if everybody else is,
I'm very forgiving with myself
as a host.
I'm like, "It's an evolution.
I messed up the teleprompter.
I got the facts --"
No, I don't -- We try not to get
the facts wrong.
-Yeah. "I'm making it up!"
-"Just go with it!"
You know, I think stepping into
the 9:00 p.m. slot on MSNBC,
previously occupied
Monday through Friday
by the great Rachel Maddow...
-Yep.
-...is a huge honor, and no one
can replicate what she does.
And I think we wanted to figure
out what the DNA of our show is
and that just takes some time.
We've tried some stuff
that's worked,
we've tried some stuff
that hasn't.
And I think luckily our audience
seems to be with us.
People are forgiving.
People are excited to see,
you know, the plane being built
on the runway.
And I'm just thrilled that I'm
still the air six months later.
-Well, I feel the same way.
One of the things you've
addressed, which I want to ask
you about, because obviously
the Republicans are coming off
sort of underwhelming midterms.
But it does seem like they're
still sticking with
this culture war message.
And one of the people you see
using that as a tool more often
than others is Florida governor
Ron DeSantis.
You've been covering the way
he's been approaching politics
via education.
Can you speak to some of
the steps he's taking
and maybe why we should be
afraid of those?
-I mean, you should be afraid of
anything that systematically
tries to disenfranchise people
and whitewash history,
which is exactly what's
happening down in Florida.
We should care about it not just
because it's Florida but also
because Ron DeSantis may end up
being the Republican nominee
for president in 2024.
But basically what he's done is
this kind of Orwellian plot
to censor what is being taught
in the classrooms
through the passage
of various legislation,
book bans and book approvals.
I mean, I was talking to
a teacher
in Manatee County this week.
They've literally had to paper
over their school libraries
and classrooms because the books
haven't all been approved
to these state-set standards.
Kids can't read books in
classrooms because teachers are
so scared they could get slapped
with a felony for running afoul
of these new standards.
Ron DeSantis has said, "I'm not
going to approve an AP course
on African-American studies
in the state of Florida
because so far I've seen
no evidence
that it has
any educational value."
I mean, this is the way we
reindoctrinate people to sort of
a white Christian nationalist
agenda, which is very much
at the heart of the Republican
sort of platform,
if you will, right now,
and Ron DeSantis has been
insanely effective in passing
this legislation,
creating a climate of fear,
and ultimately undermining a lot
of the social and cultural
progress that this country
has seen in
the last 15 and 20 years.
So I think we should all be
paying attention to it.
I've gone down to Florida. I've
talked to teachers and students.
It's part of the field work that
I think is essential
to being a journalist.
I'm surprised I'm still allowed
to enter the state of Florida,
at this point.
I hope you're not watching,
Governor DeSantis.
-I don't think he is.
[ Laughter ]
-Probably not.
-Probably not, yeah.
-"I like the monologue,
but that's it!"
-"Then I turn it off!"
[ Laughter ]
You know, he's trying to take
the one -- There's one school,
New College, down in Florida
that's the bastion
of sort of progressive thought.
He's trying to stack the board
of trustees at that college
to basically reverse the
curriculum that they have there.
I mean, everything he can do to
censor, marginalize,
whitewash, and otherwise create
a culture of
intimidation around those who
want to tell the truth about
this country and our systemic
injustices,
he's doing it, and he's doing it
with ruthless efficacy.
And now you have other states
that are looking at Ron DeSantis
and saying, "Maybe we should do
that too."
South Carolina is looking at
some of the same legislation
that they've passed in Florida.
This is the new agenda
of the right.
If you can't win fair,
win using any anti-democratic
means necessary.
-This is -- I think it's --
This is less important,
what I'm going to ask about
because obviously the outcome is
the most important and you do
have teachers who are scared
and you do have books
that are banned.
Do you think -- I know it's kind
of impossible to know that
Ron DeSantis came at this
because he was afraid of kids
reading books, or he came at
this because he wanted to be
the guy who could stand up at
a debate and say,
"I'm the guy who banned books"?
-He wants to -- This is all
political calculus.
This is -- I mean, Ron DeSantis,
if he could, the license plate
for Florida would say, "this is
where woke goes to die."
That's all he says
about his state.
That's like the selling --
That's the motto for the state
of Florida.
He knows it plays well
with people on the right
who want a culture war.
And so far, I mean,
he won handily
in the last gubernatorial race.
It's worked for him.
The question is whether
the extreme policies that
he's pursued in the state of
Florida work well
on the national stage if, in
fact, he does run for president
against Donald Trump, which is a
cage match I don't know if I'm,
like, physically, mentally
prepared for.
-I don't think Ron DeSantis is
either.
-That may be true, Seth.
-I think from a distance,
you're like,
"I can take out Donald Trump,"
and then you get on a stage,
and you're like "Oh, man, I
shouldn't have done this."
-"Maybe not, yeah."
-You have a big fan,
actually backstage.
Our next guest, Bowen Yang,
sings your praises.
Independent of you
being on tonight,
he is a huge fan of yours.
-It's a mutual admiration
society.
-Yeah. Because you hosted the
reboot of the show "The Mole."
-Yes, as one does.
-Yeah.
Well, you know, this was
the show that's always been
in the hands of journalists.
Anderson Cooper did it back
in the day.
And now you're doing it.
And was that a fun show to do?
-It was not like covering the
insurrection at the Capitol.
[ Laughter ]
You know, it dawned on me that
some people in TV have fun.
It's not that my job isn't fun,
but, like, it's incredibly
serious.
And it's a lot of traumatic
material to absorb every day.
And I thought, "Oh, this could
be really a fun experience,"
doing this crazy reboot that at
its core is a question of trust,
which, you know, I will say
there's a through line between
that and what we do in terms of
political coverage.
The central conceit in American
life today is, who do you trust,
who can you trust, who's really
being honest here?
And that's the game
in "The Mole."
So I thought, "Okay, I can
create a reason why it makes
sense for me to do this and go
to Australia for 10 weeks."
-Well, I'm very glad you got
that trip,
no matter how you justified it
to yourself.
Hey, thank you so much for being
here. I really appreciate it.
-Thanks, Seth.
-Alex Wagner.
"Alex Wagner Tonight" airs
Tuesdays through Fridays
at 9:00 p.m. on MSNBC. We'll be
right back with Bowen Yang!